now Shan how many of you are there in
America meaning how many people like you
cattle ranchers how many of you are
there in America 700,000 700,000 what
was it before was it a lot more 1979
there was well about 1.2 to 1.3 million
in between we went from 1.2 to 1.3
million to 700,000 today from 1979
that's correct
what was the biggest drop-off shed from
79 to today was there a single event
that God got rid a lot of people in your
world no it was there wasn't a single
gradual it's a gradual decline because
of the lack of competition throughout
the industry and so we have these
acquisitions and mergers take place more
power control and you know expenses go
up we're not able to create any kind of
competition in the marketplace and you
know how stuff flows downhill if there's
10 business owners that are selling
their industry meaning come get involved
in my industry one industry real estate
one industry is technology one industry
is insurance in other industries finance
another industry is you know
construction then you're standing there
and you're selling your industry could
you easily sell others to consider
getting into your industry today it's
financially impossible as an individual
it's financially impossible to give you
say that why do you say that because the
overhead it costs too much to start a
there you know it takes a lot of land it
takes a lot of overhead and unless you
what they the proverbial term and the
beef cattle industry is unless you marry
it are inherited you ain't going to have
it so and that's one of the problems
that has taken place as the result of
this you know it's hard for family you
know everybody's dream is to pass the
family farmer ranch down and that's
that's totally impossible now you can't
do it you know let's take me for example
you know my mom and dad had four small
nice tranches paid for in the early 80s
the early 80s come on and
you know if you worry you may not
remember this interest rates got up
there 17 to 21 percent there was a fall
out we lose some land well then we
basically have to start over and it's
just been an issue of that several times
since then and it's just I mean these
young kids it is impossible to get a
start up you can get some government
help as a first-time landowner or
business owner but the this the the cost
of the land it requires a lot of land
and the cost of the the inputs are
increasing and gaining and it's so it's
impossible without a lot of equity or
cash in the bank to get a start it's
nearly impossible and therefore across
America we have seen thousands and
thousands hundreds of thousands of youth
not return to the family operation after
after in high school or college because
of this specific reason correct so based
on what you know I mean I'm assuming
you're in a community where you're with
other people and you're talking to other
Kathie cattle ranchers because you're in
that world I mean insurance I talk to
other insurance yields and exec yes how
many of these seven hundred thousand you
think are going to be able to withstand
the current challenges they're facing
that's it that's a good question and I
would say that we could lose through the
ESCO good situation
we could lose plus one third of those
this year you you could lose a third so
we can go from 700,000 to 450,000 in the
next six seven months it is possible
maybe more
[Music]